hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is your first look at the samsung galaxy
s6 edge yes the rumors are true so
samsung did announce two phones today
the normal galaxy s6 and the galaxy s6
edge and i have videos out right now
about both so definitely be sure to
check out the regular s6 video actually
should probably watch that one first
it'll be the first link below that like
button so this is the slightly crazier
looking brother to the galaxy s6 and i
guess that one-sided galaxy note edge
must have worked out pretty well because
samsung is up to it again bringing the
shape to their main flagship lineup so
the s6 edge is of course nearly
identical in a lot of ways to the
regular galaxy s6 brother it has all the
same internal specs same software same
camera same materials and everything
just a slightly larger 2600 milliamp
hour battery and of course now a bit of
the display hanging over the edge of
both sides so it's still technically a
5.1 inch display diagonally but now the
whole shape of the phone is different
and actually think it looks pretty cool
especially holding it up close and
actually using it these sloping edges
make it a real head turner but not in
like an overly distracting way now
because of the display moving towards
the metal a bit closer to the edge with
the thin bezels you do get slightly
sharper edges on the sides but you're
still definitely holding metal but you
know you hear so often about the iphone
curving the edge of the glass to make it
feel more smooth when transitioning over
the edge this kind of takes it to the
next level by curving the display under
the glass also so okay what are the
benefits of getting the edge over the
regular galaxy s6 samsung's got to add a
few features in there to the edge
display to make it worth it besides just
looking good so they have edge lighting
people edge
information stream and night clock so
information stream and night clock are
things carried over from the note edge
where you can have information scroll
across the edge when it's sitting face
up or at night you can dimly show the
time on that amoled display makes sense
obviously that's not new then the people
edge is a constantly available swipe in
from the upper right sort of natural for
the thumb to bring in your most
frequently contacted people for a
one-touch phone call or email and this
is kinda cool but i really wish samsung
would have let us put anything there
like our five favorite apps or something
that would have been a legit useful
feature but for now it's just contacts
can't really change that
and you'll notice the little circle
rings around the contact names those are
actually connected with edge lighting so
when your phone is facing down and you
receive a call from one of those people
it lights up the edges of your phone
with the color of the person calling and
of course that lights up the table it's
on too it gives you a pretty good idea
of who's calling before you have to turn
it over pretty neat look not one of
those things that blows my mind but at
least it's good looking
but yeah other than that the edge
display is all about immersion that's
really what impressed me the most i just
couldn't stop looking at this damn
display it got this weird not really
distortion to it but you know viewing
angles don't suffer but it has this
different look on the edges i don't know
it's weird reflections look different
also i don't know if it was intentional
or not but with all these new android
apps that swipe in from the left hand
side this display is kind of perfect for
pulling in those drawers again i don't
know if samsung did that on purpose but
it's a really nice feeling and a sort of
a dope side effect from having these
curved over edges with the glass and i
can guarantee you won't see any other
phone with this shape out there so it's
a unique form factor it's something
different and new
i think now that it's on both sides it's
a little bit less awkward a little more
usable for lefties of course and it just
overall feels like a slightly better
design than the one-sided edge from
before it's gone from being a weird
experiment to a full-fledged flagship
and honestly if i was picking between
the s6 and the s6 edge right now i think
i would go for the edge now obviously
it's probably you know a little bit
harder to get it might not sell in all
the same places as the regular s6 but i
actually really like it so let me know
what you guys are thinking in that
comment section right below also side
note cases for this phone are gonna be
pretty awkward too
thank you guys for watching this quick
first impressions of the s6 edge let me
know what you want to see in the full
review video too when that comes out in
a little bit thanks for watching and
i'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace